les regards sont aussi tournés en cette
mi journée vers garmisch partenkirchen
le sud de l'allemagne qui accueille les
suites du g7 sommet auquel a pris part
ce matin volodymyr zelensky par
visioconférence le président ukrainien
qui s'est donc exprimé bruno daroux
bonjour vous êtes sur place notre envoyé
spécial le président ukrainien qui a
donc comme prévu réclamer davantage de
moyens pour mettre fin à la guerre
oui absolument elisabeth le président
hélène ce qui s'est donc adressé au
leader du g7 réunis ici en bavière il a
d'abord dressé un constat assez durs des
bombardements que subit son pays
15 missiles par jour en temps ordinaire
soixante cinq missiles ce week-end au
total près de quatre mille missiles qui
se sont abattues sur l'ukraine et il a
réitéré ses demandes de à
d'intensification des sanctions contre
la russie il a demandé aux dirigeants
occidentaux de s'en tenir aux garanties
de sécurité les ont promises à l'ukraine
en cas de négociations c'est-à-dire une
non appartenance à l'otan mais la mise
en pratique du fameux article 5 qui
prévoit une protection d'un pays agressé
il a abordé aussi évidemment la question
des céréales et il faut tout faire at il
dit pour que non seulement ces céréales
puisse quitter l'ukraine mais il faut
trouver aussi un moyen pour libérer les
silos actuelle tout simplement parce que
la récolte prochaine approche et puis la
demande principale en fait ac a adressé
le président zelensky à ses homologues
occidentaux c'est de tout faire de
l'aider en fait à tout faire pour que la
guerre se termine avant que l'hiver
n'arrive avant le mois de décembre parce
que at il dit si elle n'est pas terminée
à ce moment là et bien les positions
seront gelés le climat est rude les sols
seront détrempée il y aura donc
un gel des combats en quelque sorte et
du coup ça repartira au printemps
prochain et on partira alors on
s'engagera alors sur un conflit très
long donc il a vraiment insisté sur le
fait que les occidentaux devaient tout
faire pour aider l'ukraine y compris
bien sûr avec la livraison d'armes à
faire en sorte que la guerre se termine
avant la fin de l'année merci beaucoup
bruno daroux notre envoyée